Welcome to "In Context", I am David
Pakman and here in the United States we are
getting close to the third spike of
Coronavirus, Covid 19. The first spike
was, of course, in April; the second by the
end of July and now we are getting closer and closer
to the third spike. In a little bit we
will talk about the implications of that,
but first of all we are talking with the
Mayor of the City of Los Angeles, in
the State of California
Eric Garcetti. Well Mayor, it is a pleasure
tañlomg with you. For starters, a lot
a lot of early and abscentee votes in this
election, and of course we need to be
very careful with the inferences we made
based in the Coronavirus situation, but
How do you see the situation in California
about the early voting, the abscentee voting? Were there
any problems with the fake voting
boxes that Republicans put?
How are you managing everything in Los Angeles? +
- Well, I am happy about seein such enthusiasm
from the voters, not only in
California and Los Angeles but in every
part of the US,
we need all the votes from the
US residents during this
critical election, but yes, there is a lot
of people, a lot of parties, the
(?) here in California that are
playing with our votes and it is
very important to protect the right of all
citizens to vote in the elections,
not only for the President, but it
is important because there are local (ways),
there are state representatives, people
that are in this elections and
we need to protect them. Here in Los Angeles
we have
secured boxes in front of every
library, for example, but there are four
times more early voters now. Now, in this
moment, our population is not only
facing against the crisis of
Covid, but also a crisis in our
democracy. I hope this election
can finally start a new
chapter in the story of, not only
the United States, but also for us here
in Los Angeles and California too. - +Yeah, from the
point of view of the importance of
latin voters and the latin people, I
can´t remember of an election with such
importance, specifically when seeing how
the latin voters is going to determine, the
latin people in general, people from
a left wing in the United States, they vote for Democrats.
With the particular exception of
the Cuban-Americans, who tend to be the
latin voters from the Right wing, I have
talked with Deputy Debbie Mucarsel Powell
last week, and she mentioned that even
the Cuban-American people is not
particularly happy with the current
president and they are,
some of them, planning in voting Joe Biden. In
Los Angeles and California, How do you see
the different communities
from hispanic countries? + - We have a very diverse latin community,
very diverse, from many countries and many
generations. A lot of perspectives. But
in the campaing as President,
as chief of Joe Biden´s campaing, we
have the support of every different
latin community
including the Cuban community, the
boricua (Puerto Rico) community, the communities of
Central America, Mexico-Americans, from
South America... We have specific messages in
both English and Spanish from this communities
that support Joe Biden; the hearth and the
history of Joe Biden and Kamala Harris as a
daughter of inmigrants, and...
Remember the words of
Donald Trump, they are very important to
remember. For example, he has insulted
our communities, our cultures, he
(has treated) Mexico-Americans as criminals and
we are very practical,
we have a perspective when we
want a leader. Not just a "strongman" like
Trump, but someone that can
bring positive results that can actually benefit
our lives.
Joe Biden is that kind of leader, Kamala
Hariss is that kind of leader, and is
important to focus in that constrast and
remember the insults of Donald Trump when
we voted in that (last) election-
+Yes, in the latter two or three weeks in
the rallys, the president frequently
says those manufactured phrases, "I love
hispanic people", in English he says
"I love hispanics",
Why do you think he is doing that (The
president)? It is for a kind of desperation,
that he recognizes that he needs the hispanic people
to win? What do you think? +
-Well, we are winning in the campaign
of Biden and Harris the latin vote, and the
"undecided", the people that have yet
to decide their votes,
(two of every three voters) are leaving Trump
and going towards the
campaign of Biden and Harris; and that is a good
reflexion about our values. We have
a lot of trust in the latin community
when returning to a latin party, Where are we
in the administration of Donald Trump?
If he mentioned that he loves hispanic, Where are
we in the gabinet, in the
true possitions of power?
Those are just words. But the
actions,
the (base) of Democrats, is
specifically to improve the situation
about Covid 19, to reform and rebuilt
our economy and save our own lives.
With (those aspects of) climate change targeting
California, with the wild fires in the
South, with the hurricanes... it is important
to not only say things but also
act on those plans. That contrast is very, very
strong. - + In the next segment we will talk
a bit more about what you´d
like to see (happening) from the point of
view of the Covid 19 if Joe Biden wins, but
from a economic point of view;
What do you think
that the first priority of a
Joe Biden´s presidency would be,
specifically to the people of Los
Angeles and California? + - We need to
hurry our economy and provide with
more jobs, specially to the Latin
part of the community, the inmigrants, but
all of the United States needs more money,
more resources, more infraestructure. Those
are middle-class jobs, and we
have the opportunity of
bringing skilled workers in
our community schools to grow
prosperity for the next
generation.
Latin people are becoming more
and more prevalent in the workforce
of the United States, of the workers of
this country. And our plans are very
specific; targeting the energy
sector and generate green and clean energy,
invest in our streets, in our
highways, in the accses to Internet for
our students and our bussineses,
it is very specific and it is a great plan
that targets prosperity for generations, for
two to three decades; not only
to change the situation during this
crisis but (giving) a very wide vision (for improvement)
to every corner of the country.-
+We will make a brief pause and we will continue
in just a moment talking with the Mayor of Los Angeles,
Eric Garcetti. We continue now with
the conversation with the Mayor of Los
Angeles, California, Eric Garcetti, and also
co-chief in charge of the National campaign of
the Democrat candidate for presidency
Joe Biden. Mayor, talking about Covid-19,
we are nationally getting closer to a third spike,
the firs one was back in
April, the second was by the end of July and
now the cases are again rising uncontrollably.
We don´t know when the vaccine will be
available, nor we know how efficient
it will be. How do you see the folliwing
six months respect to the Covid-19, and what
could a president Joe Biden do
inmediately in January?+
-Yes, well, first of all it is important to remember that this
administration was an absolute failure
regarding Covid-19. We have 220 000 deaths, there is
no plan, the administration does not have a
plan with gobernors in the
local, state and federal levels.
Joe Biden
will bring a specific plan to our
schools, for the health (institutions), to fulfill
all the needs of our
hospitals and our medical personel, and
also a plan where science,
the doctors, are important once again.
During the Trump administration his opinons and
his political needs were
more important than the advice
of our Doctors and professionals, and it is very
important in a country when we
have just 4% of the entire population
of the world but we have over 20% of
the deaths (Of Covid). Finally
restoring the need of universal
action, with masks, with
social distancing,
with hand washing...
All of this things, there is no leadership in the
White House. There are different words,
different messages, every week and
finally with Joe Biden, as when during
(the) Ebola (pandemic), he was vicepresident,
and he will bring a plan that covers
every level of need in every corner of this
country. During this administration, the
west is suffering. The east is suffering.
The north, the mid west,
and the south is also (suffering).
We need leadership in all the country
simultaneously and Joe Biden will be a president
to the entire country.- +Talking about
national leadership,
Would you like to see a national
mandate about masks, that effectively
would not be a national mandate, but a
reccomendation,
to the Governors, to do State
mandates, But do you think that is a
good idea? + -Yes, it is a good idea,
but the power to do that unfortunately only
exists in the hands of the states, but
I hope that with a leader like Joe Biden he
could bring anyone to the
White House and work with them
to finally get that mandate in every
State.
Unfortunately,
this president, president Trump, is not
interested in this.
He wants to think that his virus will one day
just dissapear, but that is not gonna happen.
In reality, in this situation it is
very important to have standars
in every part of the country,
in every State, because
the divisions among our states is
pretty much artificial and the virus can travel
between two States in a day. That is why
it is important to have that attitude.- +When
talking about the Vaccines, Do you know anything
else that you may tell us about...
the president mentioned that right now, in October,
we would have an approved vaccine. The
CDC and other organizations say that this is
going to take longer. From the point of view
of an administrator of the city of
Los Angeles, What are
the public health experts
telling you? +
-Well, we are working towards a vaccine.
But a vaccine, even though it´s critical, can be
dangerous without the consent of the cientifical
community.
There is a sort of war against science and
the scientists of Donald Trump, but here in Los
Angeles we are preparing ourselves
for the distribution of it, it is also very
important to be prepared for the Influenza vaccine,
but also important
because of Covid 19. There are a lot of candidates
to develop a vaccine,
but we must have a safe vaccine. And only
when we have that kind of security from
doctors, and not from politicians, we
will distribute that vaccine to all
residents of Los Angeles and then
we will be able to open our economy
again, but again that is an
aspect of his (electoral campaign) for Trump. And it is
not about our health. - + We were talkin with
the Mayor of the city of
Los Angeles, in the State of California,
Eric Garcetti. It has been a pleasure, and
thank you so much for your time + -It is always a
pleasure, thanks.